sie sehen die abgeordneten stehen auf
die plätze werden gewechselt ein anderes
thema kommt die wirtschaftspolitiker
gehen jetzt steht ein innenpolitisches
thema an es geht um die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft das ist kann man
sagen ein dauerbrenner in deutschland in
der innenpolitischen debatte mit diesem
thema hat schon vor vielen jahren im
bundesland hessen damals roland koch
eine wahl gewonnen
jetzt also wird es mal wieder
angebrachtes liest nicht vor ein antrag
der fdp fraktion und natürlich die afd
möchte die doppelte staatsbürgerschaft
abschaffen spricht gottfried curio für
die fdp sehr geehrter präsident sehr
geehrte abgeordnete die verleihung der
deutschen staatsbürgerschaft ist keine
gefälligkeit leistung des deutschen
staates kein willkommensgeschenk für
kinder von ausländern schon gar kein
integrations beschleuniger eher im
gegenteil
was also dann sie darf nur antwort sein
auf eine zu fordernde
integrationsleistung dessen der
deutscher staatsbürger werden will
antwort auf ein definitives und
ausschließliches bekenntnis zu
deutschland
im jahr 2000 hatte rot-grün das geltende
recht der staatsbürgerschaft zerstört
sie wurde grundsätzlich verschenkt an
kinder mit geburtsort deutschlands
damals noch befristet spätestens mit 23
musste man sich zwischen der deutschen
staatsangehörigkeit und der der eltern
entscheiden 2014 hat die groko unter
ihrer rot-grünen kanzlerin diese
optionspflicht abgeschafft und uns
diesen doppelpass auf dauer beschert die
afg fordert das rückgängig zu machen
staatsvolk ist wahl volk und wahl volk
anstatt grundgesetz und demokratie aus
den angeln heben ein zur regel
entarteter doppelpass untergräbt staat
und demokratie
wollen wir nicht dass jemand mehrere
staatsbürgerschaften anhäuft muss
begründete ausnahme bleiben schließlich
akzeptieren wir in deutschland ja auch
nicht zwei drei oder vier ehefrauen oder
etwa doch und integration wenn denn
angezeigt nicht nur temporär schutz
berechtigten wenn integration also
gelingen soll dann sollte der
zugewanderte fremd stadt wirklich hier
ankommen sich auf das land in dem eine
neue heimat finden möchte einlassen und
einlassen wollen
mit dem geistigen rückfahrschein in der
tasche nichts anderes ist der pass des
zweit staats wird dies schwerlich
gelingen ohne die pflicht der
entscheidung für einen staat fehlt jede
motivation sich zu integrieren man lebt
man gern in einer wachsenden blase fremd
staatliche identität einer bloß
verpflanzten version des heimatlands als
ausländer der nur die vorteile der
deutschen staatsangehörigkeit mitnimmt
so etwas will kein staat dass es nicht
im interesse deutschlands das lehnen wir
ab
und warum überhaupt sich integrieren
wenn ein ganz anderes nahe gelegt wird
etwa von einer sogenannten
integrationsbeauftragten selbst ein
musterbeispiel misslungener integration
wenn sie erklärt sie habe in deutschland
keine deutsche kultur erkennen können in
die hinein man sich integrieren sollte
stattdessen müsse das zusammenleben
täglich neu ausgehandelt werden das
meine damen und herren das nennt man den
bock zum gärtner machen welchem land
gehört nun die politische loyalität der
doppelstadt an niemand kann zwei herren
dienen soll verdi erdogan diktatur
unterstützt die deutsche politik
mitbestimmen wollen wir fremd
einflussnahme bei der gesetzgebung als
türöffner für standard zu einer
lebenskultur die unserem
rechtsverständnis widerspricht wir
kennen die geburtenraten es bedarf
keiner phantasie soll klein anatolien
berlin neukölln soll syrien soll in
afrika jetzt nicht nur hier wohnen
sondern bald direkt die deutsche politik
bestimmen müsste hingegen bei
wiederhergestellte optionspflicht
politischer einfluss wahlrecht erst
erkauft werden durch verzicht auf die
mitgebrachte staatsangehörigkeit gebe es
diese probleme weniger fremd kulturelle
zonen außen bestimmte politik in der
gesellschaftliche konflikte all dies
kann deutschland nicht wollen wir wollen
deutsche selbstbestimmung und bewahrung
des inneren friedens
[Applaus]
man erinnere sich der aufrufe erdogans
an seiner türken sich in deutschland
nicht zu assimilieren oder seines rads
macht nicht drei kinder sondern fünf
denn ihr seid die zukunft europas
was die ideologie einer feindlichen
übernahme offen ausspricht oder seiner
aufforderung bestimmte deutsche parteien
nicht zu wählen wenn es noch irgend
eines nachweises der gefahren beim
doppelpass bedurft hätte hier wird er
prompt geliefert
auch die cdu auch die cdu liebe kollegen
wollte jüngst die optionspflicht wieder
haben und die schwarzen nehmen es hin
dass ihre rot-grüne kanzlerin so einen
parteitagsbeschluss mal eben wegwischt
als gäbe sie nicht herr kollege vor ihr
gestanden während richten nein es darf
doch nicht darum gehen dass hier
lediglich partei soldaten salutieren
sondern es muss doch in deutschland
gehen verehrte kollegin entdecken sie
auf dem grunde ihrer schwarzen partei
identität einmal ihr blaues gewissen
bekennen sie sich zu ihrem eigenen
partei beschluss folgen sie frau merkel
nicht sondern handeln sie für
deutschland und stimmen sie zu meine
damen und herren das war die rede von
gottfried kurie und der kommentator muss
sagen da fällt mir nicht viel zu 1
das ist ein weltbild das ich kaum
kommentieren kann so fremd ist es und so
eigenartig und auch auf deutschland
bezogen machen wir einfach weiter in der
debatte marian band cdu/csu der
bundestagspräsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen auch heute haben wir gerade
wieder eindrücklich zu hören bekommen
wie die afg versucht uns hier
vorzuführen
aber ich sage ihnen eins
wir als union wir als union brauchen uns
von innen beim thema doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft nicht vorführen
lassen das tun wir auch nicht wir werden
nur noch nicht jagen lassen wie sie es
suchen denn wir haben beim thema
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft eine ganz
klare und deutliche position und
brauchen erst recht keine belehrungen
von der sogenannten alternative meine
kolleginnen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen eine staatsbürgerschaft ist
mehr als ein bonbon was man einfach mal
so mitnimmt
sie ist ausdruck für mich der tiefen
verbundenheit in dem land dem man lebt
sie zeigt für mich die verwurzelung in
diese gesellschaft und die damit
verbundenen rechte und pflichten
man nimmt übernimmt mit ihrer
verantwortung nach der prägnanten
formulierung von joachim gauck treten
auch für zugewanderte in unsere
verantwortungsgemeinschaft einfach einen
pass zu bekommen damit man es bei der
einreise einfache hat das ist mit der
union nicht möglich die cdu und die
union hat mit dieser klaren und
einfachen positionen bereits 1999 die
wahl in hessen gewonnen und auch auf dem
bundesparteitag der cdu haben wir uns
ein deutlich für die abschaffung der
doppelten staatsbürgerschaft und die
einführung der optionspflicht im
grundsatz ausgesprochen
die optionspflicht wir kommen noch warum
die immer noch besteht die
optionspflicht da war nämlich einen
fehler beim kollegen curio die
optionspflicht halte ich nämlich für
eine sinnvolle regelung für menschen die
hier geboren sind und deren eltern aus
lang sind sie sollen entscheiden ob sie
sich für das land und die gesellschaft
der eltern verantwortlich fühlen oder
sie können verantwortung für unser land
übernehmen indem sie den deutschen pass
annehmen niemand kann aus meiner sicht
zwei gesellschaften dienen
immer wieder wird es loyalität konflikte
geben wer länger in unserem land lebt
soll und darf sich auch zu diesem
bekennen können
die französischen hugenotten zb die vor
200 jahren einmal eingewandert sind sind
mittlerweile auch alle deutsche geworden
und haben sich zu unserem land bekennt
ich darf ihnen vielleicht auch ein
gelungenes beispiel liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen für einen solchen
integrationsprozess geben und wie
wichtig es ist dass man sich für eine
sache auch entscheidet thema sucht das
singen kam vor zehn jahren mit seiner
frau als inder in meiner heimatstadt
er betreibt ein restaurant beschäftigt
vier bis sechs angestellte und bezahlt
gut und gerne steuern sowie
sozialabgaben
wir verstehen uns blendend und könnt
vortrefflich natürlich über politik
streiten ist voller stolz hat in der
letzten september berichtet dass er
einen einbürgerungstest bekommen hat und
am 28 september des letzten jahres ist
er deutscher staatsbürger geworden als
sich im oktober immer wieder besuchte
zeigt immer voller freude seine ausweise
die einbürgerungsurkunde und auch den
durchgestrichenen indischen pass denn
für ihn war klar er möchte hier in
deutschland leben
ihm gefällt unser heimatstadt torgau
sehr und er lehnt deswegen die indischen
staatsbürgerschaft ab und nahmen voller
stolz die deutschen
und zur krönung das darf ich vielleicht
noch sagen hier ist er sogar cdu
mitglied geworden und aus dieser ja das
ist ein weg das ist ein weg ein
bekenntnis auch dass man sich nicht nur
formell zu einem stadtbekannten auch
inhaltlich an diesem mit tun möchte
solche beispiele liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen braucht ist mehr denn sie sind
der schlussstein einer erfolgreichen
integration und ein bekenntnis zu
unserem land
die cdu sachsen schlussfolgert
richtigerweise auf ihrem letzten
landesparteitag dazu die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft hat sich als
integrationshindernis erwiesen deshalb
lehnen wir es ab dass kinder
ausländischer eltern in deutschland
automatisch deutsche werden der
optionszwang muss wieder gelten wer
wirklich deutscher werden will braucht
keine weitere staatsbürgerschaft
und nun könnte sich ja
ganz entspannt und nun können sie sich
fragen warum stimmen wir dann darf die
nicht zu weil unsere begründungen für
die ablehnung der doppelten
staatsbürgerschaft diametral wirklich
diametral unterschiedlich sind und
einiges an einem blick in die
gesetzesbegründung ihres antrages belegt
dass auch schon die begriffswahl mit der
unverhohlenen herabsetzung von
nichtdeutschen im text zitat fremd
stadler und zitat fremdkulturellen
personen genannt zeigt ja abermaliges
anliegen abschottung ausgrenzung und
diskriminierung
ihr text suggeriert ganz einfach das
problem sind die ausländer und für das
problem haben sie sogar einen namen
gefunden die türken
dabei gibt es laut statistik mindestens
genauso viele russische wie türkische
doppelstaatler aber nicht wenn es gibt
den impuls einer zwischenfrage als
direct wir verschließen uns den debatten
nicht und deswegen lassen sie zu vielen
vielen dank herr kollege
sie sagen ja gerade dass sie uns in der
sache schon zustimmen
jetzt gucken ja hier auch eine ganze
menge bürger zu können die jetzt für
sich mit nach hause nehmen dass sie hier
so politik machen dass sie dinge nicht
nach ihrem inhalt und nach der wirkung
die sie entfalten beurteilen sondern nur
danach von wem sie kommen
herr kollege wenn sie mir wenn sie
werden sich zugehört hätten habe ich
mich sehr inhaltlich mit ihren
argumenten auseinandersetzen mit der
gesetzesbegründung ich habe er nicht
gesagt ich lehne es ab weiß von ihnen
kommt nein ich habe ihnen das
beschrieben und wir werden gleich sogar
noch weiteres von mir hören warum wir
das inhaltlich ganz konkret ablehnen und
von daher ist auch kein problem schon
hier und auch keinen ich sage mal so
richter keinen konflikt und ich werde
sogar noch gleiche leute und warum
aktuell die optionspflicht er weiter
besteht wenn sie sich auch mal
inhaltlich mit den gesetzen dieses
landes tiefe ausnahme setzen würden und
nicht pauschal in überschriften und
basis denken würden wir waren ja bei den
punkt der statistischen daten
es gibt in deutschland genauso viele
türkische russische doppelstaatler aber
das verschweigen sie einfach warum war
dann müssten sie ja die russen als fremd
staatliche nicht aufgeklärte
lebenskultur bezeichnen so wie sie es
mit den türken im antrag machen und
diese doppelmoral der kann man nicht
zustimmen
für die union hat eine
staatsbürgerschaft vor allen dingen auch
etwas mit stolz mit verantwortung und
werten zu tun aber diese worte die
kommen gar nicht vor
sie sind nur vom negativen geprägt und
es liegt auf der hand dass sie nur von
der hand des hasses geführt wurde
die hand die diesen gesetzentwurf
geschrieben hat und wenn sie sich noch
einen blick mal eine aktuelle
ausländerrecht begeben würden dann würde
sich feststellen dass die optionspflicht
im grundsatz eingeführt bleibt denn es
kann nur der seinen doppelten pass
erhalten der sich integriert hat dafür
haben wir ganz harte faktoren definiert
die sich an der dauer des aufenthaltes
definieren am spracherwerb auch am stand
der ausbildung also grundsätzlich muss
man sich entscheiden
außer man hat gewisse
ausnahmetatbestände erfüllt die ein
bekenntnis oder die davon zeugen dass
man ein bekenntnis abgelegt hat zu
diesem land auch zu
diesen werten liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich darf abschließend noch
einmal für die unionsfraktion noch
feststellen
wir sind grundsätzlich für die
beibehaltung der optionspflicht bis zum
23 lebensjahr
sie ist für uns eine kernforderung und
wir werden noch immer daran arbeiten
dass die deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
weiterhin ein wert von freiheit stolz
und verantwortung ist und die
bürgerinnen und bürger sich dahinter
auch versammeln können vielen dank
florian war das für die cdu csu fraktion
auch er hat die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft als integrations
hemmnis bezeichnet zusammen mit teilen
zumindest der union
aber man wollte sich von der afg
andererseits nicht jagen lassen das hat
er mehrfach betont weiter geht es mit
sebastian hartmann für die spd fraktion
zu dem thema der aussprache kommen
schlage ich vor dass wir als
parlamentariern und parlamentarier
gewählt worden sind solidarität mit
einer kollegin aus hamburg erklären in
hamburg geboren ist und als
staatsministerin soeben in diesen
premium bezeichnet worden ist als
beispiel gescheiterter integration meine
damen und herren das hat die frage der
staatsangehörigkeit nicht verdient dass
wir eine einzelne kollegin so
diffamierend herausstellen nicht lenkt
es widerspricht der würde dieses hauses
so in der frage der staatsangehörigkeit
zu versuchen einen zusammenhang zu
konstruieren für die eigene gute
begründung
denn wer heimat gegen herkunft aus
spielt der spaltet wider besseren
wissens unsere gesellschaft und
gefährdet den friedlichen zusammenhalt
in unserem land meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist es
umgekehrt nicht zwei pässe lösen an
loyalität konflikt aus sondern das
aberkennen einzelner teile der eigenen
identität lösen erst an
loyalitätskonflikt aus meine damen und
herren
deswegen ist die spd stolz darauf dass
wir uns in wesentlichen schritten für
die modernisierung des
staatsangehörigkeitsrechts eingesetzt
hat wer im jahreswirtschaftsbericht der
bundesregierung beklagt dass chancen
verpasst werden dass menschen nicht
einwandern wollen in unseren staat und
dann gleichzeitig das recht der
mottenkiste aus dem kaiserreich wieder
herausholen wollen im
staatsangehörigkeitsrecht von 1913 das
zurückgehen wird die spd nie an der
seite haben wir sind stolz darauf dass
wir die aktionslicht mit der großen
koalition 2014 abgeschafft haben
auch wenn die union nun auch wenn die
union versucht an zweifellos
untauglichen ausfallschritt nach rechts
zu machen aber erneut wie im dezember
dezember 2016 haben wir unter dem
eindruck des cdu bundesparteitages
erneut die frage des zurück nehmens der
optionspflicht diskutiert liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
damals konnte der staatsminister der
union nicht erklären warum auf einem cdu
bundesparteitag die junge union irgendwo
mal frau merkel angreifen wollte und
dann verlangt hat dass diese
staatsangehörigkeit frage zurückgedreht
wird es war klar dass wir mit der spd
vereinbart ist dass hat bestand wir
werden diese realität konflikt in
unserem land nicht nur auf machen sie
sind damit keinen millimeter weiter
gekommen
doch wenn die sächsische cdu behauptet
sie hätte irgendetwas anderes zu sagen
sie können sich in ihrem eigenen laden
nicht durchsetzt und das ist gut so
meine damen und herren
und wenn wir noch mal auf den punkt
kommen ja es gibt die beispiele von
doppelter staatsangehörigkeit in
deutschland wir haben sie klar geregelt
wir haben das in schritten 2000 getan
wir haben es 2008 getan indem wir dann
noch ergänzungen der reformen zugenommen
haben warum sollen wir das im jahr 2018
zurücknehmen wir haben eine gute
regelung gefunden und diese regelung hat
bestand auf die zahlen ist der kollege
wendt ja schon angegangen es betrifft
eben nicht nur menschen die einen
türkischen hintergrund haben sondern
auch menschen aus polen
was kasachstan aus russland und sie
haben sich für deutschland entschieden
das ist ein unterschied
es gibt millionen von deutschen die
nicht wenige sekunden noch nicht wenige
minuten oder wenige stunden oder jahre
nach ihrer geburt in deutschland im
kreißsaal niemals danach gefragt worden
sind wieder in ihr bekenntnis zum
deutschen staat unseren grundwerten und
grundrechten aus wenn das die lektionen
der diskussion heute ist dass wir das
noch mal verstärken wollen was der
demokratische grundkonsens unseres
demokratischen rechtsstaates ist hat
diese fehlgeleitete debatte doch noch
einen moment gebracht meine damen und
herren die spd bekennt sich am modernen
staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wir sichern
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft und
wir spielen die eine gruppe nicht gegen
die andere aus wir wollen dieses land
nicht spalten wir wollen es stärker
machen soweit sebastian hartmann von der
spd-fraktion der hier am anfang seiner
rede noch mal eingegangen ist auf seine
kollegin aydan özoguz die ja besonders
von der afd von ihrem
fraktionsvorsitzenden gauland seinerzeit
angegangen wurde der sie in so wörtlich
anatolien entsorgen wollte weiter geht
es jetzt mit jürgen martens von der fdp
fraktion
ich fühle mich beschämt uns zuhause
zugleich zum einen beschämt weil ich
nicht gedacht hätte dass in diesem haus
an diesem ort im deutschen parlament
noch wieder solch die familien des
gerede und völkischen floskeln verwendet
und fühle mich zugleich zu hause weil
ich im sächsischen landtag zehn jahre
lang neben den nazis der npd sitzen
musste aber schließlich auch mühe geben
meine damen und herren von der afd
an deren bus heftigkeit kommen sie noch
nicht ganz ran im verhältnis zu denen
sind sie ein kindergeburtstag wenn auch
ein kindergeburtstag mit vielen
grauhaarige herr kollege machen sie
herzlich ein freies kollegen brandner im
moment nicht danke man erst reden möchte
ich ungestört meine damen und herren das
verlangen nach der abschaffung der mit
der wiedereinführung der option wird
begründet damit die gewährung der
staatsangehörigkeit so als sei dies ein
gnadenakt würde ein bekenntnis
voraussetzen ja welches bekenntnis
sollten einen säugling ablegen können
ist mein vorredner schon erwähnt auch
der deutscheste säugling kann kein
bekenntnis
meine damen und herren in der tat als
jurist weiß man in der tat als du wirst
weiß man dass wichtige steht im
kleingedruckten und deswegen lohnt es
sich ihnen die begründung dieses
gesetzentwurfes einmal durch zu sehen
eine auseinandersetzung mit der
faktenlage irgendwelche wertungen oder
prognosen künftiger entwicklungen werden
sie dort vergeblich suchen meine damen
und herren
stattdessen finden sie dort unbewiesene
behauptungen unterstellungen oder jetzt
in der mündlichen begründung dinge
braucht vom völkischen kategorien wie
irgendwelchen geburtszahlen
entwicklungen meine damen und herren
wenn behauptet wird dass
konfliktpotenziale das zusammenleben in
einer gesellschaft mit massenhafter
doppelter staatsbürgerschaft ich sag
jetzt zieht ihre prägenden meine damen
und herren dann spricht er eine
besondere wahrnehmung heraus
tatsächlich sind wir davon weit entfernt
in deutschland leben nach mikrozensus
2015 1,7 millionen menschen mit
doppelter staatsangehörigkeit vor einer
übernahme der deutschen politik durch
doppelstaatler sind wir damit weit
entfernt
sicher lange dass die optionspflicht
menschen dazu zwingen soll sich auf
deutschland geistig einzulassen was
immer das heißen mag aber so als ob
doppelstaatler dies nicht oder nur in
geringem maße täten und im umkehrschluss
weiter gedacht heißt dass ausländer
lassen sich auch deutschland sowieso
nicht geistig 1
das ist die konsequenz daraus jetzt
frage ich sie haben sie dafür
irgendeinen beleg irgend einen
klitzekleinen nein wir die freien
demokraten glauben nicht dass identität
aus einem pass folgt und man könnte sich
dem thema der staatsangehörigkeit durch
leid durchaus sachlich nähern das tun
sich allerdings hier nicht meine damen
und herren wir freien demokraten wollen
diese frage allerdings in einem
umfassenden gesetzeswerk behandelt
wissen in einem einwanderungsgesetz und
in einem staatsangehörigkeitsrecht aus
einem guss und nicht mit kleinen
einzelne schüsse irgendwo herum dort
meine damen und herren und nicht glaube
in dieser legislatur wird es so weit
kommen dass wir uns ernsthaft über ein
einwanderungsgesetz unterhalten ich
glaube die mehrheit des hauses hält dies
für notwendig
und die fdp wir wollen auch eine
doppelte staatsangehörigkeit
das muss grundsätzlich möglich sein mehr
als die hälfte aller länder macht dies
möglich und doppelte staatsangehörigkeit
betrifft zum großen teil menschen die
aus anderen ländern der europäischen
union zu uns gekommen sind das ist die
unmittelbare folge der freizügigkeit
innerhalb der europäischen union meine
damen und herren
und das ist geht es schlecht einwanderer
müssten deutsche staatsbürger werden
können und wir werden uns darüber zu
unterhalten haben
die afg antrag insbesondere seine
begründung und die debatte hier genügen
dem schon inhaltlich bei weitem nicht
vor allen dingen ist dieser antrag wieso
fast alles von der afg zutiefst
fremdenfeindlich grundiert es wird sie
deswegen nicht wundern dass die fdp
diese man dem gesetzentwurf nicht
zustimmen kann
soweit also jürgen martens für die
fdp-fraktion der hier seine erste rede
im wohnhaus gehalten hat und darauf
abgehoben hat wie es für ihn war im
sächsischen landtag neben abgeordneten
der fdp zehn jahre lang zu sitzen weiter
geht es mit niema movassat für die
linksfraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
was die afg heute als gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt hat ist echt schwer erträglich
sie wollen die möglichkeit sowohl die
möglichkeit der doppelten
staatsangehörigkeit abschaffen das wäre
ein integrationspolitischer rückschritt
das lehnen wir als linke ab r weite
teile ihres der begründung ihres
gesetzentwurfs sind schlichtweg ekelhaft
da gehen sie von fremd kultureller
herkunft fremd staatlicher lebenskultur
fremd einflussnahme nicht aufgeklärten
kultur der gesetzentwurf ist ein
sammelsurium völkischer begriffe und sie
sich sprechen und menschen mit doppelter
staatsbürgerschaft ab geistlich deutsch
zu sein ja gehts noch sie beleidigen
millionen menschen in diesem land sie
tun so als ob es eine deutsche
lebensweise gibt an die sich alle zu
halten haben
das ist nicht nur falsch ein bayer denkt
vermutlich was anderes über das
deutschsein als ein schleswig-holsteiner
sondern ist es zutiefst autoritär was
sie vorgelegt haben sie von afg scheint
das grundgesetz auf 69 jahren nach
seiner verabschiedung nicht verstanden
zu haben denn laut unserer verfassung
ist die bundesrepublik ein
freiheitlicher staat jede und jeder kann
im rahmen der gesetze so leben wie er
oder sie mag das grundgesetz schreibt
eben keine bestimmte lebenskultur vor
ist halt pech für die afg und glück für
uns alle dass wir nicht ihre völker
autoritäre lebenskultur annehmen müssen
in ihrem gesetzentwurf sprechen sie von
massenhafter doppel staatlichkeit ich
empfehle ihnen sich die zahlen des
statistischen bundesamtes oder des
zensus von 2011 an zuschauern maximal
fünf prozent der bevölkerung haben eine
doppelte staatsangehörigkeit das hat mit
massenhaft nichts zu tun
hören sie mal auf deck news zu
verbreiten sie sprechen menschen mit
doppelter staatsangehörigkeit die wie
sie es nennen loyalität zur
bundesrepublik ab sie tun ja gerade so
als ob menschen mit doppelter
staatsangehörigkeit agenten sind eine
verschwörungstheorie muss und offenbar
jeder half die initiative rein und dann
kommt ein punkt der oft ja gegen die
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft vorgebracht
wird die einflussnahme des türkischen
regimes auf deutsch türken und sieben
sinne des autokraten erdogan zu einem
beeinflussen erstens diese einflussnahme
ist natürlich zu verurteilen aber das
hat mit der doppelten staatsbürgerschaft
wenig zu tun denn genau so wäre es
denkbar dass das erdogan regime um
einfluss auf die deutsche politik zu
nehmen die leute animiert nur die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft zu behalten
wenn eine doppelte nicht möglich ist und
ja sie sagen menschen mit doppelter
staatsbürgerschaft können rechts regeln
brechen brechen das kann jeder mensch
nazis in diesem land brechen ständig die
rechtsregeln sie zünden asylheim sie
verletzten menschen simon wo bleibt
eigentlich da die empörung der afd
die hfg behauptet der gesetzentwurf
diene der integration ist es echte der
witz des jahrhunderts wenn sie wissen
wollen die integration geht schauen sie
sich mal die bisherigen anträge der
linksfraktion an
das wichtigste ist dass menschen die
dauerhaft hier leben die die gleichen
pflichten die deutsche staatsbürger
haben auch die gleichen rechte erhalten
wir brauchen ein
staatsangehörigkeitsrecht dass
integration fördert dazu gehört die
möglichkeit der mehrstaatlichkeit dazu
gehört die möglichkeit der einbürgerung
nach fünf jahren aufenthalt wir brauchen
freiwillige kostenlose und alltagsnahe
staatsbürgerschafts kurse und
sprachkurse
anstatt darüber zu diskutieren wie wir
migranten ihre rechten nehmen können was
ja anscheinend die einzige triebfeder
der afg ist sollten wir darüber reden
wie wir die demokratie für alle menschen
in diesem land stärken können wir haben
in deutschland acht millionen erwachsene
die hier steuern zahle hier schon
teilweise lange leben und die nicht
wählen dürfen das sind zwölf prozent der
erwachsenen das ist ein echtes
demokratisches defizit
wir brauchen endlich ein
fortschrittliches staatsbürgerschaft
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht und ein
wahlrecht für alle die dauerhaft hier
leben das wäre ein echter beitrag zur
integration
niemand war das für die linksfraktion
weiter geht es mit vielen polat bündnis
90/die grüne sie ist migrations und
integrationspolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren meine fraktion ist zutiefst
schockiert
über die begründung des gesetzestextes
aber herr curio hat ausdrücklich mit dem
begriff entarteter pass wir dem ganzen
eine krönung aufgesetzt sie die familien
damit millionen von doppelt
staatsbürgerin auch in diesem parlament
hier sitzen mehrere abgeordnete mit
doppelter staatsbürgerschaft mit
mehrstaatigkeit stellvertretend für die
realitäten in unserer migrations
gesellschaft dass es absolut
inakzeptabel und beschämend
und meine damen und herren wir erwarten
auch von allen fraktionen dass wir hier
gemeinsam ganz klar die grenzen
aufzeigen und erwarten das auch von dem
präsidium dieses hohen hauses
meine damen und herren zu einer offenen
globalisierten und modernen gesellschaft
gehört eine politik der mehrstaatigkeit
deshalb ist meine fraktion gegen die
optionspflicht ohne wenn und aber den
denn der optionszwang bedeutet dass
junge deutsche unter dem damoklesschwert
einer drohenden ausbürgerung aufwachsen
und letzten endes dazu gezwungen werden
sich für eine staatsangehörigkeit zu
entscheiden
eine solche politik wäre sachlich
absolut falsch und integrationsfeindlich
sie würde wieder dazu führen dass
deutsche anderen deutschen beweisen
müssen dass sie deutsch genug sind um
deutsche zu bleiben insofern ist diese
optionspflicht absoluter irrsinn und
geht an der lebenswirklichkeit in
deutschland und im übrigen auch in
diesem parlament völlig vorbei meine
damen und herren deutsche haben
heutzutage unterschiedlichste wurzeln er
victor perli hat drei
staatsangehörigkeiten der ordner von
holz zwei staatsangehörigkeiten
namibische herkunft dr daniel baier
türkischer herkunft doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft ich sage ihnen wer
eine migrations gesellschaft gestalten
möchte sollte alles daransetzen dass
sich menschen in unserer freiheitlichen
und demokratischen gesellschaft
zugehörig fühlen dass sie deutsche sein
werden und auch bleiben dürfen meine
damen und herren
dass wir hier beraten das haben die
kolleginnen und kolleginnen gesagt ist
nicht nur einfach die forderung der
wiedereinführung der optionsregelung
darüber kann man streiten diskutieren
das haben wir auch zum zu genug tue mit
der union getan aber meine damen und
herren es wurde in der rede deutlich die
begründung des gesetzestextes sie ist
wirklich eine offenbarung für die
fremdenfeindliche fremdenfeindlichkeit
dieser partei hier im rechten sah auf
der rechten seite dieses hauses es wurde
bereits gesagt da ist von fremd starken
fremden kulturen die sich zu einer
explosiven mischung verdichten die rede
wer die tagebücher von anne frank
gelesen hat wird merken
dort werden genau dieselben worte
verhindert wer verwendet fremd stadler
ist nämlich ein begriff aus der
judenverfolgung des nationalsozialismus
eine initiative mit einer solchen
sprache und begründung auf die
tagesordnung des deutschen bundestages
zu setzen
zwei tage nachdem wir hier im bundestag
den opfern des nationalsozialismus
gedacht haben dass es beschämend
helgoland
und nun auch noch ein wort zur loyalität
frage was ist das maß was sind die
kriterien für loyalität sind es
diejenigen ihrer partei die das system
abschaffen wollen die uns den krieg
erklären ist es die kanzlerin die ihre
leute an den galgen hängen was ist mit
denen ihn in jeder partei die putin
huldigen oder von trans schweren
schwärmen aus auf welcher
wissenschaftlichen grundlage beruht
eigentlich der vorwurf eine doppelstadt
lerin könne gar nicht in demselben maße
dem deutschen staat gegenüber loyal sein
wie ein deutscher ohne zweite
staatsangehörigkeit
meine damen und herren ich komme zum
schluss ganz ehrlich mit dem bekenntnis
zum grundgesetz sehe ich eher bei
manchen mitgliedern der s&d-fraktion
nachholbedarf nicht bei uns
doppelstaatler drinnen liebe afd
die hannoversche allgemeine zeitung
titelte am 29 august letzten jahres
parallelgesellschaft afd und trifft es
damit auf den punkt nicht doppelstaatler
geflüchtete oder weltoffene menschen
sind die parallelgesellschaft sondern
sind vielen dank vieles blatt war das
für bündnis 90 die grünen die sich hier
abgearbeitet hat vor allem an der
wortwahl des antrags der afg und deren
loyalität zum grundgesetz in frage
gestellt hat weiter geht es jetzt mit
michael kuffer für die cdu csu fraktion
schon nach wenigen minuten dieser
debatte wird wieder einmal deutlich dass
heute der typische oppositions ansatz
nämlich die politik ist die kunst des
demonstrativen mit dem verantwortlichen
und den regierungseinsatz politik ist
die kunst des möglichen kollidieren wird
ja die frage der staatsbürgerschaft
stand schon mehrfach im zentrum
schwieriger politischer
auseinandersetzungen und war
schlussendlich gegenstand mühsam
errungener kompromisse aber die art und
weise
wie sie meine damen und herren von der
afd
ihre generelle abschätzig kite gegenüber
kompromissen zur schau stellen ist
befremdlich und er sagt es ausdrücklich
gesagt es ausdrücklich in richtung ihrer
demokratischen einstellung die sie damit
offenbaren und weniger in bezug auf ihre
inhaltlichen argumente soweit sie welche
vorbringen und zugegeben
der kompromiss ist manchmal nichts für
schwache nerven
aber er gehört zu den wichtigsten
lebensadern der demokratie und ihm zu
suchen gehört zu den daseinsberechtigung
'nen des parlamentarismus
meine damen und herren von der afg
agrarland wenn sie hier schon immer so
großen wert darauf legen dass die
demokratisch gewählt sind dann würde ich
ihnen herzlich an empfehlen dann
verhalten sie sich auch einmal
demokratisch und dann funktioniert auch
unser zusammenleben und unsere
zusammenarbeit in diesem parlament
sie verwechseln sie verwechseln
in der art und weise wie sie wie sie
hier einzelne kollegen mit begriffen um
mit vergleichen belegen sie verwechseln
permanent politische gegnerschaft mit
feindschaft und da fragen wir wirklich
was ist mit ihnen eigentlich los
letzte mal zum inhaltlichen die
staatsbürgerschaft ist und das ist doch
unbestritten die intensivste form der
bindung an einen start
deshalb ist ja dieses thema nicht
einfach zu lösen
eine bindung die notwendigerweise mit
einer besonderen loyalität verbunden
sein muss
und natürlich ist es schwer vorstellbar
diese loyalität zu teilen ja in conflict
fragen sie zu spalten
es bleibt richtig man kann nur einem
herrn denen man kann sich nicht doppelt
verheiraten
und wir wissen ja zu dem was sie sagen
was wir wissen dass die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft integrations hammond
sein kann
und ja wir mussten erst kürzlich am
beispiel des referendums in der türkei
leben dass die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft ein anreiz für
ausländische regierungen sein kann
in die inneren angelegenheiten unseres
staates hineinzuregieren ja wie über das
instrument einer zweiten ausländischen
staatsbürgerschaft der versuch
unternommen worden ist deutscher
staatsbürger aus dem ausland in nicht
hinnehmbarer weise unter druck zu setzen
deshalb sage ich ihnen zunächst ganz
klar folgendes die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft muss ein ausnahmefall
bleiben
sie darf nicht zur regel werden und das
ist für die union im übrigen völlig klar
für die gleise im übrigen auch völlig
klar ist im übrigen auch manchmal nutzt
es dann schon mein blick ins gesetz
wirft dass die optionspflicht nicht
abgeschafft worden ist die
optionspflicht ist weiterhin der
grundsatz sie ist nur für die hier
aufgewachsenen eingeschränkt worden
ansonsten bleibt sie als grundsatz im
paragraf 21 absatz 1 das zentrale
element in dieser frage des
staatsbürgerschaftsrechts aber liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zum
vollständigen bild gehören auch einige
erfahrungen aus einem anderen
blickwinkel zb dass es bei den
betroffenen zu einer entfremdung von
deutschland kommen kann bei
integrationswilligen zu einer
entfremdung kommen kann wenn eine so
weitreichende entscheidung zu viel
aufgezwungen wird
und das sage ich deshalb bei dass auch
nicht das ziel einer vernünftigen
integrationspolitik sein kann und ich
sage es auch mit blick auf die
wirtschaftspolitische debatte von heute
morgen
es kann auch um im hinblick auf den
fachkräftemangel wirtschaftspolitisch
nicht besonders klug sein
gut ausgebildete gut integrierte
fachkräfte teilweise auch akademiker
ohne not in das land ihrer eltern zurück
zu treiben anstatt alles zu tun um sie
hier zu halten
zu einem anderen blickwinkel gehört zb
auch dass die durchsetzung der
optionspflicht mit unverhältnismäßigen
kosten bürokratischen aufwand verbunden
ist bei dem gleich schenken umstand dass
etwa die hälfte der fälle in etwa die
hälfte der fälle die mehrstaatigkeit
schon aus anderen gründen akzeptiert
werden muss etwa weil die aufgabe der
ausländischen staatsbürgerschaft
unmöglich oder unzumutbar ist um diese
beiden seiten der medaille in einen
ausgleich zu bringen
tritt die cdu csu fraktion für den
sogenannten generationen schnitt 1 dh
die mehrstaatigkeit diejenigen die in
deutschland aufgewachsen sind wird
hingenommen während sich die darauf
folgende dritte generation dann für eine
der beiden staatsbürgerschaften
entscheiden muss er mir scheint dass
dieser weg des generationen schnitt auch
angesichts der bei den
staatsangehörigkeit fragen naturgemäß
sehr aufgeladenen politischen
gefechtslage kompromissfähig es in
diesem sinne bitte ich die anderen
fraktionen hier im hause diesen weg zu
unterstützen
einen letzten satz zum gesetzentwurf der
afd der meine damen und herren ist aus
einem ganz einfachen grund schon von
vornherein nicht zustimmungsfähig
nämlich deshalb weil ich keinen sinn
darin erkennen kann dass wir hier im
deutschen bundestag als legislative
gesetze beschließen die nachher die
judikative sprich des
bundesverfassungsgericht wieder
kassieren muss so wie sich ein
gesetzentwurf nämlich angelegt haben
führt er eindeutig zu einer rückwirkung
bei der frage der wiedereinführung der
optionspflicht für bestimmte gruppen sie
wissen oder sie sollten wissen dass ein
solcher ansatz verfassungswidriges das
schafft man natürlich nur wenn man sich
jenseits der großen geste hier am
rednerpult mal bereit wäre auch mit
fakten und mit details zu beschäftigen
und dann würde das auch schaffen
gesetzentwurf vorzulegen dem man dann
vielleicht einmal zustimmen kann vielen
dank
michael kummer war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der bevor er hier den
antrag der afg auseinandergenommen hat
ihnen vorgeworfen hat sie verwechselten
permanent politische gegnerschaft und
feindschaft weiter geht es jetzt mit
josip juratovic für die spd
ihrem ruf als monothematische anti
ausländer partei gerecht zu werden mit
ihrem gesetzentwurf gegen die doppel
staatlichkeit werden sie ein thema
wieder auf an dem sich cdu/csu schon
abgearbeitet haben mit union hatten wir
vor drei jahren nach zähem ringen die
aussetzung der optionspflicht
durchgesetzt und gegen ihren willen
beibehalten
jetzt will die ard diesen kompromiss
geben
und warum weil sie gegen ausländer immer
gut stimmung machen lässt das thema
staatsbürgerschaft hat schon einmal
wahlen entschieden wir erinnern uns an
die unerträglichen unterschrift sammlung
bei der wahlen in hessen bei der die
menschen gefragt haben woran ich gegen
die ausländer unterschreiben kfd möchte
diese unzählige tradition fortsetzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja wohl
jawohl ich gehöre zu der sogenannte
gastarbeiter generation eine generation
die dieses land seit sechs jahrzehnten
schulter an schulter mit den deutschen
kolleginnen und kollegen aufgebaut hat
und zwar unter schwierigsten bedingungen
die bäuerliche den brauchen sie noch
heute
wir reden das selbsternannte vaterland
und vertreter von der afg von denen
nicht bekannt ist dass sie diesem land
bislang keine großen dienst erwiesen
hätten
dass diese leute dass das erweitern die
genugtuung verweigern wollen dazu
gehören noch nicht einmal der den
kindern solle die deutschen
staatsbürgerschaft haben dürfen ohne
ihre herkunft verleugnen zu müssen
im gesetzentwurf der fdp heißt es sogar
wenn integration gelingen soll muss der
fremd stadler was für ein wort das in
deutschland leben wirklich hier ankommen
und sich auf das land einlassen wollen
dann möchte ich an dieser stelle mal
ganz klar stellen
integration hat nicht jeder zahl der
presse zu tun
die haben die jemand hat integration ist
identifikation identifikation mit diesem
land dieser gesellschaft in der man lebt
unsere gesellschaft der region gesetzt
im ersten artikel auch die
unantastbarkeit der menschenwürde
hinweisen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
gesellschaft ist eine gespaltene
gesellschaft nicht nur in der frage
deutscher oder ausländer sondern
vielmehr insgesamt in der frage der
gelebten werten und haltungen ja
menschen
das spiegelt sich auch hier im parlament
wieder das hat aber nicht mehr der
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft zu tun
sondern mit der stimmungsmache der fdp
und ihrem gesetzentwürfen es ist nämlich
ganz anders als in ihrem gesetzentwurf
schreiben
das hat da heißt es die jetzige
aussetzung der optionspflicht führe und
ich zitiere automatisch zu einer
massenhaften jahr regelhaft und doppel
staatlichkeit jetzt zu vermeiden gilt
großer gott immer diese massen von denen
die ard spricht da wird ja einem jahr
ganz bange bleiben wir doch zur
abwechslung bei konkreten zahlen
laut statistischem bundesamt verfügen in
deutschland knapp zwei millionen
menschen über zwei besser
das sind nicht einmal zweieinhalb
prozent der deutschen bevölkerung
ich meine das ist selbst für kritiker
verkauf bauen davon
und das ist interessant sind 870.000
gebürtige deutsche
das heißt zu einem ist die zahl derer
die zwei bands haben
auf dieser schau war und zum anderen
profitieren auch gebürtige deutschen von
dieser möglichkeiten was soll also diese
gesetze lautet liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir müssen menschen mit
migrationsgeschichte und deutsche
selbstverständlich gleichberechtigt
behandeln und endlich damit aufhören
ständig an ihrer loyalität zu zweifeln
wird die afg offen macht das erschwere
die integrationsbemühungen auf beiden
seiten viel mehr sie spielen die
menschen denn erdogan putins dieser welt
in die hände der sozialdemokraten wissen
um den reichen reichtum unserer
gesellschaft deutschland ist dann seiner
vielfalt zu einem land geworden dass
weltweit bewunderswert ist ein land auf
das ich stolz bin und das wollen wir
aufgrund unserer gemeinsamen werte und
tugenden aufrecht erhalten und wir
werden uns da nicht von irgendwelchen
völkischen gespinsten der fc kaputt
machen lassen
zum schluss es ist wieder die währungs
durch afg anträge am menschlichen
herkunft und schicksale hier abarbeiten
stadt bessere lebensbedingungen für die
menschen zu schaffen und zwar
gleichermaßen für deutschland wie für
die ausländer herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
josip juratovic war das von der spd
fraktion der hier viel applaus aus fast
allen fraktionen des hauses bekommen hat
von allen außer der af ddr spaltung
vorgeworfen hat die loyalität auch
derjenigen die im ausland geboren sein
zu diesem land der sei groß und im
übrigen seien ist gerade mal zweieinhalb
prozent der bevölkerung die einen
doppelten pass über die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft verfüge das dürfte
doch kein großes problem sein sagte
soweit also josip juratovic für die spd
fraktion